I'm sure somewhere out there in the
infinite possibilities there was a
version of me that thinks this is a good
idea I really thought I was gonna take
the night off
tonight but I just I have to deal with
this so when I did my video just the
other day talking about Disney acquiring
Fox and how x-men could be integrated
into that world and I had floated a
general idea because I mean there's no
reason to keep x-men as a separate
universe I mean marvel's entire thing is
having a single cohesive universe and
I'm not saying that's the only way to do
it in fact heck I wish Warner Brothers
would have gotten off trying to do a a
shared universe in a continuity a while
back and just stuck to individual
franchises but that's what Marvel has
been able to make it's big it's coherent
it's consistent that's kind of their
whole deal they would it wouldn't make
sense for them to start something with
x-men that doesn't connect back so it's
going to get integrated now a lot of
people like a shocking number at least
shocking to me suggested some form of
alternate reality some form of you know
multiverse breaching basically and I
responded to the first few of those I
saw most of my responses could be summed
up as some very end up no no no no no no
no no no no no and I got tired of typing
that out every time so now I'm gonna do
this cuz I feel like I need to explain
why I don't think that's a good idea and
I will admit my bias right up front I'm
not a big fan of multiverse stories as a
thing especially in regards to comic
book material and superheroes now I'm
not saying there's no such thing as a
good multiverse story I'm not an idiot I
know some of them are good I'm just
saying that so that it's a general thing
that I don't love for me when you do a
multi-dimensional you know alternate
universe crossing over story generally
it works
best if you're telling a very you know a
very singular tale very tight very
contained it exists for the purposes of
this I feel the same way about
time-travel stories in a lot of ways
when you're telling a very specific
story using that as a function of that
story fine it can work brilliantly but
when you try and use that as a narrative
device in a bigger sprawling epic
universe that has way more going on than
just this little multiverse or
time-travel crossover thing you do then
honestly you tend to just make a mess
and I'm not against the idea of
alternate dimensions alternate versions
of things I mean I love Elseworlds and I
I'm fine with all that it's just the
stories where things cross over I tend
to not really like they have a tendency
to honestly just be massive continuity
wanks I mean the iconic multiverse story
is DC's crisis on Infinite Earths which
existed solely as a massive continuity
thing and I mean and sort of singling
out crisis on Infinite Earths in a lot
of ways emphasizes what I don't like
about the use of crossing over
multiverses as a thing and it also
points to why I don't think it's a good
idea because the primary reason or at
least the official primary reason for
why DC did the crisis on Infinite Earths
event which if you don't know a ton
about that
DC Comics had had a multiverse and
multiple reserves like an earth one and
earth to all these different variants
and you know sometimes the characters
would cross between them but in the 80s
they collapsed it all down into a single
universe through an event they called
crisis on Infinite Earths a big part of
the reason why they did that is because
they were having trouble growing their
sales beyond their existing customer
base they were having a real hard time
luring new people in and they determined
that one of the reasons probably not the
only reason maybe not even the primaries
and it's really hard to say this stuff
is is difficult to parse out and it's
all based on tests and focus groups um
whatever but they did come to the
conclusion that part of the problem is
the multiverse is confusing and it's
off-putting for a new or more casual
fans and anecdotally my experience backs
that up that's part of the reason I
couldn't ever really get into DC because
multiverses and crossing between them
and doing stuff with them has always
been more DC's thing than Marvel's I
mean Marvel has multiple universes it
technically does have a multiverse it
does exist but DC is much more into just
actually milking stories out of that
then Marvel tends to be so maybe that's
my first thing I feel like multiverse
stories are DC's bag and not Marvel's
bag in the first place but that again
that story existed basically just to do
continuity and it wasn't even a bad
story but the fact is it was a
continuity fix first and a narrative
second and that is the kind of approach
to storytelling that I'm sorry gave us
Batman V Superman because that movie was
built around not only the intention of
moving Superman forward in the in the
timeline and the arc that Zack Snyder
wanted to do but it had to include
Batman and it had to include Wonder
Woman it had to set up the Justice
League and it had to set up dark side
and it had to do all these things not
because it actually served the core
narrative of that movie but because it
had to do all this continuity stuff
there was a bunch of elements of that
movie that were continuity first and
helpful to the narrative a distant
second so you gotta watch out for
prioritizing that way I think it's very
rare that a story that's being told
primarily as either a marketing or
continuity fix is almost never a truly
great story in and of itself but sort of
getting back to what I was saying that
sort of layered and very complex
continuity is incredibly rewarding for
hardcore fans and people who stick with
it but is off-putting to casual fans and
I've said this before and I will keep
saying it people like me and like I kind
of assume most of my subscriber base the
people who are really in and enjoy
digging through and picking through the
minutia and absorbing all the stuff the
hardcore people we need to understand we
are not enough to keep these franchises
going on film because film is expensive
these move
are expensive and we alone cannot make
them profitable they have to have some
degree of mainstream appeal if they
start putting off the mainstream by
doing things like integrating a
multiverse which is confusing and
off-putting if you're not really into
all the detail stuff these things aren't
gonna make the money they need to make
to keep going what are you gonna be on
it I just don't think there's anything
to be gained out of trying to introduce
the x-men into the MCU through some sort
of multiverse tactic and also I want to
point something else out because a
couple of people in the comments brought
up a man the wasman like oh they said
they're bringing in the multiverse no
they didn't well they sort of did but
not the way you're now claiming because
you're talking about two different kinds
of multiverse what ant well actually the
first Ant Man and also Doctor Strange
brought in was this idea of different
realms different layers of reality the
quantum vers the dark not dark universe
or whatever the heck it was that
Dormammu existed in so that stuff is
being introduced but that's not the kind
of multiverse that you're talking about
when you're talking about the sort of
continuity reality ripping different
versions of characters coming in because
that is more about alternate alternate
versions of the reality that we know as
opposed to completely different types of
reality which is what things like the
quantum verse and dormammu's realm
actually are so no Marvel has not laid
in the groundwork for a multiverse not
in that way that having been said I do
understand that there are or soon will
be elements in the MCU that will allow
for multiverse not only existence but
crossover it would be very simple
there's a lot going on I mean but the
Infinity Gauntlet alone you wouldn't
even need the whole Infinity Gauntlet
just the reality gem it could give you
enough leeway to mess with things to
create alternate versions and bring in
you know the x-men from another reality
you wouldn't even necessarily need that
they haven't really specifically laid
out exactly how scarlet witch's powers
work in the MCU they seem a little bit
more key but traditionally her powers
are reality-warping so she already
appears to be getting stronger and if it
gets laid out that what she is actually
doing is actually warping and affecting
reality they could push her to a
that she actually tears a hole in
reality and creates all this stuff so
and I'm sure these other possibilities
so when I say this is a bad idea I don't
think there's a lot to be gained from it
I'm not saying it's not possible
logistically it's absolutely possible I
still just think it's a bad idea
and the main reason I think it's a bad
idea is why why would you do that as
opposed to just starting fresh and I
know there are issues with marble just
trying to bring in mutants I talked
about some of them in my last video I
don't want to rehash a ton of them but I
do acknowledge that there are issues
with how Marvel is going to get things
integrated but I think the issues
involved with that are smaller than the
issues you caused by creating this weird
multiverse scenario and again I'm gonna
ask what is there actually to be gained
because you would think the big thing
that you would want by by doing this
thing of saying that the and the Fox
x-men movies were another reality now
it's crossing over and there it's gonna
mix with the MCU who would be to bring
over the specific visions of those
characters and more importantly the
specific actors playing them but with
all due respect to James McAvoy and
Michael Fassbender the best and most
iconic versions of the core characters
those actors are done with this
franchise Patrick Stewart's not gonna
play Professor Xavier again Ian McKellen
is not gonna play magneto again but even
if I accept that okay maybe we get
McAvoy maybe we get Fassbender there's
still a giant hole that you're left with
and it's shaped like Wolverine cuz Hugh
Jackman put his final stamp on the thing
with Logan he's not coming back and
there's no way that Marvel isn't going
to want some version of Wolverine he is
the biggest name in x-men so they're
gonna need to do their own version of
him no matter what and because they
can't get Jackman back they're gonna
have to recast anyway so what would the
benefit be of bringing over part of this
reality but then another part of it is
weird and different and again I
understand you could explain like oh
well they're from that one
reality that is the Fox XP universe but
we pulled a Wolverine from another
reality and it's this new actors like
again you could do it but this is all
stupidly overly complicated and again I
come back to the question what are we
actually gaining by doing it that way
look I like McAvoy I like Fassbender in
these roles but I don't like them enough
to go through this kind of weird
pretzeling of the entire MCU I think the
only character that gets a pass is
Deadpool because he's a fourth-wall
breaking character anyway so rules don't
necessarily need to apply to him the way
they do with everybody else but as far
as the rest of the x-men universe goes
again I'm gonna ask this why would you
necessarily want to port it over anyway
because look there's a lot of specific
films in the x-men franchise that I like
I mean I've talked about the side
projects more recently but even looking
at the main series I like Days of Future
past a lot first class is pretty good I
think it I think it's a little overrated
with the way some people say it's the
best one
I would love X to x-men United but even
that series like doesn't really have
much in the way of continuity and I'm
not just talking about the recasting I
mean basically every film made after
x-men The Last Stand in some way
contradicts or doesn't fit Fox kind of
eventually hit the point where this one
with which for them honestly was a
really good mood because once they were
freedom trying to make the continuity
make any sense anymore they did things
like Deadpool Logan Legion which
probably are things that wouldn't have
existed if they were really having a
death grip on maintaining a coherent
continuity and again worked well for
them but Marvel has a continuity that
works why would you why would you
integrate something from another
universe that's just gonna mess all that
up
and again look I get multiverses do have
their value they have their fun but when
you have something that is as solid as
the MCU is at this point I just I don't
see any benefit that actually comes and
whatever little benefits you get that
you have I think is completely undone by
the damage in the over complication that
cause by doing this sort of thing and I
do I feel like they've got a pretty
sizeable task for figuring out what to
do with x-men because if there was if it
was completely free rain and they could
make any possibility work let's be
honest x-men is a better fit for
television than it is for movies it's a
huge ensemble cast you could shift focus
on which character we're getting for app
from episode to episode so we don't run
into what happened with the films which
is that every single film has to focus
on Wolverine or Professor X or Magneto
and then later mystique and everyone
else is just background noise you can
eliminate that by having a television
show where they can each have a point of
focus and actually the way that I think
would be ideal to do it is you have
films that focus on the primary most
popular if we're being honest x-men the
most you know your Wolverines your
Magneto's your Professor X's and so on
and you have to get their characters
there and they'll be kind of background
like they always were but those
characters who are background in the
film you also have in a TV series where
they get to be front and center and feel
like they shined and they get their
proper due as characters cuz there's a
lot of characters that have shown up in
the x-men movies but who literally
basically just shown up and it feels
like they've never gotten their proper
due and some of them include my favorite
characters but as much as I love that
idea they can't do it because until I
curl mutter dies I'm gonna say and I'm
not saying I'm wish him dead I don't
there's very few people I wish death on
so but until for some reason he gets
removed you have to keep in mind Kevin
Feige runs Marvel films I Pro model runs
Marvel television the two men do not get
along this is why there isn't direct
crossover between agents of shield in
the movies anymore so Marvel does have a
big job ahead of them and I get that
some people think oh multiverse doesn't
that make it easy well no it makes it
easy for you cuz you watch all of this
stuff you watch all the MCU you watch
all the Fox x-men you watch everything
so you can make the leap from connecting
this to this and how it all fits
together but again we are gonna lose the
mainstream audience and we we need them
to make the box-office because if we
don't make the box-office these things
get profitable they stopped getting made
and that is not me saying like we must
compromise to make it more adjustable to
the casuals that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying we can't get overly
self-conscious Ori we can't we need to
avoid fan wank and I'm sorry to my way
of thinking multiverse continuity
correction driven stories our fan wank
most audiences don't care we can still
tell great wonderful stories that are
true to these characters and our
adaptations of stories from the sorts of
material that we love that does not also
Haley innate the the mainstream audience
we don't have to kowtow to them but we
also need to not be shoving them away
just to do something completely
self-indulgent and again from where I
sit
that's what multiverse storytelling is
incredibly self-indulgent but those are
my reasons why of all the possible ways
to integrate x-men into the MCU I do not
want any version variant of alternate
reality alternate timelines multiple
dammit no I don't want to see you and
before you try and quote me that well
Star Trek did it with the movies and
that worked did it though did it really
because all the fans ever did was
complain about how it wasn't like it was
before and they eventually ended up
losing mainstream interest anyway in the
third one which a lot of Star Trek fans
think is the best one have the worst box
office because people didn't stick
around so don't try and cite that to me
as a way in which it works cuz they
didn't really work did it and that do
that kind of little more confrontational
that night usually try and be I think
I'm just tired is the problem I I really
needed to take tonight off but I didn't
I ranted at this camera because I needed
to get it out of my system and also
because I love you people so those who
have talks on all of this whatever your
thoughts are drop something out in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
it's available on Apple podcasts as well
as stitcher radio and also what happens
to punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
calmly
for all this stuff is down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]